now that we've explored both Sufism
which is often referred to as Islamic
mysticism and Christian mysticism
extensively I suppose it is only natural
that we should move on to the third of
the major abrahamic religions Judaism
and explore its mystical tradition
needless to say there is a whole lot to
explore here and is a daunting
undertaking now when most people think
of Jewish mysticism they will
automatically think of kabalah and
kabalah is indeed an important part of
this story and will show up later on but
that's precisely the point it is a part
of the story while many simply equate
the terms cabala and Jewish mysticism
things are more complicated than that
cabala could be seen as a certain kind
of Jewish mysticism but there are other
expressions and types within this wider
category across history so what is this
wider General category of Jewish
mysticism and how can we understand its
history and characteristics that is
precis what we're going to talk about in
this
[Applause]
episode this video is a kind of
collaboration with two of my dear
colleagues and Friends Justin Sledge and
zie slavin from Seekers of unity and
esoterica not respectively the other way
around I messed it up but still uh I'm
doing this together with them not in the
usual way of us doing separate videos
but they will both be showing up in this
video to tackle topics that that they
are particular ly um well versed in to
really give give you a proper
introduction to some of these very
complex aspects of Jewish mysticism so
what do we mean when we say Jewish
mysticism I don't really think we have
to define the term Jewish or Judaism
here so what about the second term we
discussed the term mysticism its
problems and possible definitions in the
last episode about Christianity where we
pointed out that the term often denotes
experiences of reactions to and
preparations for or quote unquote Union
with God but in that video we settled on
a more nuanced and careful working
definition based on Bernard mcin who
said that it is in the Christian context
at least quote belief and practices that
concerns the preparation for the
consciousness of and the reaction to
What can be described as the immediate
or direct presence of God we might
generalize that even more by adding that
it is a direct encounter with the
presence of the absolute which is often
equated with God usually in the
traditions and context but mysticism and
Jewish mysticism is more than that too
it's a whole tendency within Judaism
that includes certain features and
characteristics a leading scholar of
Jewish mysticism Elliot wolson puts it
really well when he says quote it is
possible to isolate two distinct
concerns running through all the major
texts that Scholars include in the
Corpus of Jewish mysticism on the one
hand there is the claim to an esoteric
knowledge whose content will naturally
vary from one period to another that is
not readily available to the masses
through the more common Avenues of
religious worship ritual or study the
second major element identifiable in
Jewish mystical literature is the
emphasis placed on intense religious
experience the particular form of this
experience varies but it usually
includes one or more of the following
Heavenly Ascent vision of the Divine
form angel ification or mystical Union
the word mysticism will be used here to
refer to those trends of thought in
Judaism that lay claim to either an
esoteric knowledge of the godhead
theosophy or to an intense religious
experience of a Visionary or unitive
sort ecstasy though I do not think these
two can always be separated in a clear
and distinct manner these points should
be kept in mind as we move through the
episode in fact with all this in mind
mysticism can be found all over the
history of Judaism in different ways
expressing itself in different ways and
taking on different forms but arguably
always being there in some way or
another as early as we can possibly go
into the very days of the Israelite
biblical prophets we have clear
indications that the very prophetic
experience itself is in some way
mystical in ancient Israel with its cult
centered in Jerusalem there were as we
all know several prophets that appeared
from time to time to relay messages from
God often involving criticisms of the
way the Israelites lived and worshiped
and these prophets seem to have had very
powerful experiences as part of the
revelatory process which could even be
induced by things like music and dancing
this becomes even more apparent in the
later medieval Jewish thinkers such as
myones who conceives of a theory of
Prophecy that is decidedly mystical the
person gradually perfects his intellect
of faculty and spirit until it is so
perfect that it receives an overflow of
Revelation from God directly to the
intellect he says quote know that the
true reality and quiddity of Prophecy
consists in its being an over flow
overflowing from God may he be cherished
and honored through the intermediation
of the active intellect toward the
rational faculty in the first place and
thereafter towards the imaginative
faculty this is the highest degree of
man and the ultimate term of perfection
that can exist for his species and this
state is the ultimate term of perfection
for the imaginative faculty the
mysticism of biblical prophecy is
perhaps most clear and striking in one
particular account the famous vision of
his
Ezekiel in the very opening to The Book
of Ezekiel in the Hebrew Bible we are
presented with a positively shocking and
almost psychedelic experience where the
Prophet has a vision of the throne
Chariot of God surrounded by fire and
strange frightening creatures with
several heads Wheels inside Wheels
covered with eyes it's an absolutely
mindbending account of a direct
encounter with the Divine that can
certainly be called mystical and would
continue to be an important inspiration
for later expressions of mysticism ISM
too moving just a little bit ahead in
history we also should mention the
literature and intellectual movement in
Judaism often called
apocalypticism which give us some of the
most long-lasting features not only of
later Judaism but also of Christianity
and Islam in this literature there are
certainly mystical elements such as in
the books of Enoch which describes how
the titular character ascends on a kind
of heavenly Journey being taken up by
God quote unquote and eventually being
transformed into the angel Metatron
making it some of the earliest examples
of ascent literature which would be so
important to mysticism of course and in
the earliest forms of Jewish philosophy
we also find features that many would
certainly conceive as
mystical the ever important and
fascinating Pho of Alexandria a middle
platonist Jewish philosopher who often
read the Bible esoterically according to
platonic philosophy introduced many
ideas that would be recurring in the
history of
mysticism despite being Jewish he would
become more influential arguably in
Christian ity but his impact in Jewish
thought is not insignificant either for
example he talks about the fact that the
human being can have mystical
experiences of the vision of God and
even achieve Union with God or an aspect
of God a theme that we will definitely
return to perhaps the first kind of
mystical movement within Judaism
especially after the uh biblical
prophetic period um is a movement that
appears in the first few centuries ad so
just after the U uh um the fall of the
second temple um and it's the period of
course when Rabin Judaism as we know it
really started to to develop and this is
a kind of mysticism that is often
referred to as Mera and heot mysticism
which means uh chariots and palaces
respectively and this is a really really
fascinating type of mysticism that often
involves uh Ascent or rather sometimes
descent as we will see and visions of
this Chariot throne of God which is of
course as you probably have guessed
directly related to this vision of
Ezekiel that we mentioned earlier to
give you an overview of this incredible
kind of early Jewish mysticism here is
Dr Justin Sledge from the channel
esoterica to tell you more since the
early modern period Jewish mysticism has
become basically synonymous with the
cabala the speculative theosophy
centered around the Divine dynamism of
the spote or Divine emanation
however for nearly
800 years prior to the rise of the
cabala it appears that the mystical
Ascent literature known as Mera or
Chariot heot or Palace mysticism was the
primary form of Jewish mysticism perhaps
from roughly the period of the
destruction of the second temple maybe
even back earlier to the people like the
prophet Ezekiel until the rise of the
cabala in the 13th century so what was
Mera or Chariot mysticism I'm Dr Justin
Sledge from the channel
esoterica Mira mysticism takes as its
Central aim a journey into the Divine
realm to ultimately bear witness to the
presence of God anchored in the visions
of Ezekiel chapter 1 and Isaiah chap 6
there the prophets make the mystical
Journey to the Divine throne room where
in in ezekiel's Vision at least God's
Throne is imagined as a kind of Chariot
composed of Quasi Angelic beings
positively psychedelic quasi Angelic
beings and in Isaiah Isaiah the prophet
is gifted with a vision of the Divine
worship the glory of God by the seraphim
Angelic beings of fire Scholars debate
to what degree those narratives are
purely literary or the result of actual
mystical phenomenology I suspect the
latter just as much as the former and to
to what degree those experiences were
idiosyncratic to those specific priest
prophets or representative of a larger
Priestly prophetic mystical tradition
frankly we're never going to know
however with the rise of apocalyptic
Judaism through the and following the
Babylonian exile numerous a veritable
library of texts were composed detailing
mystical Journeys through the cosmos and
into the Divine Realms in some of those
texts these Journey culminate with the
transformation of the mystical Pilgrim
into Angelic beings themselves after
beholding or
even sitting on the Divine Throne the
most famous of these texts being the
three books of Enoch even early in the
days of the Jesus movement what will
come Christianity the Apostle Paul
claims himself in the book of second
Corinthians to have been taken up into
the third heaven and given a vision of
the Divine Glory
as nothing less than the resurrected
Jesus as Christ as Messiah further early
such mystical Visions were also reported
among the generation of the rabbis those
known as the tanim the what would become
the comp compositors of the mishna in
those narratives were told of four
rabbis who journeyed to the mystical
Garden Of Heaven however the journey is
fraught with Peril there are illusion
tests to test their worthiness to enter
the divine realm and all but one of
these rabbis failed the test one
becoming insane one dying and one
becoming a heretic after seeing the
angel Metatron sitting on the throne of
God only the Rabbi Akiva descends and
ascends and peace elsewhere in the
talmudic literature there are even very
strict prohibitions on talking about
these topics to the point where it says
it's better not to have even been born
than to publicly speak on these topics
while Scholars aren't quite sure how it
does appear that in parabanic circles of
this period and later there emerged a
school of Mystic descent they're usually
referred to themselves as y de Mera
descenders to The Chariot wherein
certain rabinal Hebrews typically Rabbi
AKA and Rabbi Ishmael make their way
through the Palaces or heot of the
Heavenly Realms they bypass terrifying
Angelic Guardians with quasy magical
codes and symbols to eventually enter
nothing less than the throne room of God
sometimes being personally transformed
into beings of fire a bit like angels
and or joining in the Divine service
with the seraphim the Divine avoda the
worship of God what has survived down to
us from this form of mysticism is
basically a small library of Amer V
literature composed over several
Centuries with mystical narratives of
these Journeys magical codes apparently
used to bypass these Fierce Angelic
Guardians of the Divine Realms in this
literature the angels are much more like
Cosmic Marines frankly and the ecstatic
hymns and songs uttered in those
heavenly palaces some of which have
actually made their way down to this day
in Jewish litery a particularly shocking
text in this literature is the shoroma
or the measure of the vastness wherein
the physical dimensions the physical
dimensions of God's body the measured in
a unit of Persian unit called the
parasang along with the secret names of
the literal body of God are given
Scholars have even argued that the
rationalism of myones theology may very
well be a kind of indirect assault on
this very type of divine mystical
anthropomorphism otherwise
unprecedented in Judaism sadly we know
very little basically nothing about how
this mysticism was performed the only
sustained discussion and I mean by
sustained I mean a couple of sentences
is mentioned by the Haan at the turn of
the first Millennium of the Common Era
he writes you may perhaps know that many
of the sages hold that when a man is
worthy and blessed with certain
qualities and he wishes to gaze at the
Heavenly Chariot and the Halls the heot
of the angels on high he must follow
certain exercises he must fast for a
number of days he must place his head
between his knees and he must whisper
incantations to himself certain Praises
of God with his face toward the ground
as a result he will gaze into his
innermost recesses of his own heart and
it will seem as if he saw the seven
halls with his own eyes moving from Hall
to Hall to observe that which is found
therein another related text the sarur
literature in which an angel is actually
summoned down from heaven to teach
rapidly the secrets of the Torah to
these par rabinal figures includes even
stricter impositions of ritual piety
fasting study and prayer truly athletic
spiritual aestheticism it's very likely
that these techniques varied from
teacher to teacher and were primarily
transmitted orally but seem to have been
able to induce a kind of trance-like
hallucinatory state wherein one traveled
down descended into the Chariot thus the
amova literature including the shorma
and the sarur literature constitute a
form of Jewish mysticism that endured
for centuries maybe even over a
millennium these mystical texts and
traditions are found throughout the
ancient Jewish world and at times
resemble the magical practices similar
to those found in the Greek magical papy
and the various mystical forms of ascent
literature found among the gnostics and
in those of the Hermetic schools of
philosophical spirituality the the
America V literature and perhaps its
practice would also eventually make its
way into Central Europe among the German
pietists in the Early Middle Ages a
center of Jewish medieval occultism more
generally however with the development
of the theosophical speculation around
the Divine emanations are theot in Spain
and France in the 12th and 13th
centuries Mera mysticism in general
would become to be assimilated into the
emerging School of cabala indeed Mera
text can also be found in the
foundational text of the cabala the book
of Radiance or the safer Zohar this
would simply Mark a new period in the
history of Jewish mysticism and an
evolution an evolution of Jewish
mysticism of ascent to the Divine
however the merav himim El Adon
continues to survive in the weekly
Jewish liturgy and is one of the many
instances of profound mystical
esotericism making its way into the
everyday world of the prayer life of
Judaism if you're interested in learning
more about America V mysticism are
actually reading some of the texts of
this tradition there is several
scholarly book recommendations over in
the description Bo I have to warn you
with much academic publishing comes much
expense these books are not cheap
unfortunately and if you're interested
in learning more about esotericism both
Jewish and non-jewish esotericism check
out my channel esoterica but now back to
my colleague and dear friend Phillip
thank you so much Justin and for anyone
who is interested um Justin's channel
esoterica is truly a gem of religious
studies YouTube and philosophy YouTube
he's just he's just amazing in so many
ways so check out uh that channel
especially if you're interested in
topics like esotericism the occult this
fascinating merkava and heot mysticism
was very prominent and popular during
the first Millennium ad it was practiced
by rabbis and prominent figures of
Judaism at the time and was essentially
the main form of Jewish mysticism for
most of History until the proper birth
of kabalah in the 13th century but with
that said Jewish mysticism was much more
complex than this too and there were
many different mystical movements and
developments during the first Millennium
among them were the composition of books
that would become fundamental for the
development of cabala the most important
of these are probably the safer Ys and
the safer habah here the safer Ys or
book of creation is an absolutely
baffling work it's quite famous around
the world and has shown up in pop
culture like in that episode of the
xfiles and usually in connection to
stories about the Golem but what this
book actually is as the title suggests
is an exploration of how God created the
world through the 22 letters of the
Hebrew alphabet and a mysterious concept
which it calls the spot belly ma
and you may recognize this concept as
the spot would become perhaps the most
central part of cabala later on
representing the emanations of God in
the safer Ys however which came out long
before works like the Zohar it's highly
unclear what the SPO bellima actually is
supposed to be other than that they are
that there are 10 of them Scholars
really disagree and there is no
consensus on the details of this system
although some have argued that the
author of The saer yats was influenced
by neop
pythagoreanism and that these spot are
some kind of mathematical geometric
concept that is Central to reality
whatever the case this work explores how
God uses the spot along with the letters
of the Hebrew alphabet combining them to
create the world thus establishing some
of the core and most lasting themes in
Jewish mysticism albeit in A Primitive
form namely the spot at least in name
and the importance of the Hebrew letters
and their mystical powers as for who
wrote the book and when the scholars are
just as perplexed here too um there have
been some suggestions that it was
probably written during the talm modic
period so maybe around the year 500 give
or take a few centuries um it really is
a baffling text that we know
surprisingly little about uh given how
important it has been for the history of
Jewish mysticism and just Judaism in
general but it's a truly fascinating and
very significant and important mystical
text the second book The saer habah here
or Book of Illumination is equally
important if not even more in some ways
it is also of Highly uncertain and
debated authorship but was probably
composed sometime in the 9th century ad
or perhaps slightly earlier with that
said though there have been various and
widely different claims some Jewish
Traditions dating it to the 1 Century ad
but other academics dating it to as late
as the 13th century so needless to say
it's an open question in any case this
book is significant for various reasons
among them because many consider it the
first proper work of what would become
kabalah now to be clear kabala as we
know it didn't exist yet at this time
but in the sa Raba here we see some of
the key Concepts and claims of cabala
formulated for the first time
essentially the book is a kind of
midrashic commentary on the Bible and
particularly on the Book of Genesis and
the creation account and what's so
significant about this book is that it
takes many elements of mystical lit
lature and philosophical speculation at
that time and sort of combines it so for
example it takes this idea from The Seer
yet of the spot the spot bellima but
also sort of combines that with
philosophical speculation probably
neoplatonic in origin about the
relationship between the infinite God
infinite absolute and creation um to
create a kind of synthesis between these
two where this relationship is explained
in some way through these spot so in the
saer bah here the way that God that that
is the infinite creates the finite world
is through emanations in stages going
from the absolute infinite apophatic
divine all the way down to the world and
these energies or stages of God's
emanation are the
spot in other words here the spot take
on the form that we all know in love and
we'll go into further details about this
system later on so in this environment
we see a diversity of different kinds of
Jewish mysticism some kinds that are
very particular and prominent at that
time such as meraba mysticism but also
the earliest whisperings of things to
come AR Klan who has written a popular
translation of the work says about it
quote until the publication of the Zohar
the bahir was the most influential and
widely quoted primary source of
cabalistic teachings it is quoted in
virtually every major book on kabala and
it is cited numerous times by Rabbi
Moshe benma ran in his commentary on the
Torah it is also paraphrased and quoted
many times in the Zohar and it is indeed
at this point well into the Middle Ages
that some significant things really
start to happen particularly in
Southwestern Europe in southern France
and Spain we see over the course of the
12th to 13th century the development of
what will become widely known as cabala
later essentially becoming synonymous
with Jewish mysticism
now we must be clear right from the
start that there isn't a kabalah but
rather many different kinds of kabalah
even in this early period this was a
highly active and flourishing
intellectual environment Spain had been
a place where Jews Muslims and
Christians had lived together for
centuries under Islamic Rule and while
this situation of course wasn't without
its conflicts and tensions it had been a
time and place of unusual levels of
cross-pollination and inspiration across
religious lines philosophers like IB
bajah IB T and IB Rush on the Muslim
side worked alongside Jewish thinkers
and inspired many of them such a the
massively important Moses myones on the
Jewish side furthermore Sufism often
called Islamic mysticism had also become
quite popular and widespread in the
region and already by the 12th century
we see Jewish writers clearly being
influenced by Sufi piety and practice
such
as the duties of the heart a book
essentially on ethics and spiritual SL
mystical practice in other words this
was a very vibrant time with a lot of
intellectual debate on various sides
myones and his rationalistic writings
which interpreted Jewish scripture and
religion according to philosophical
Aristotelian principles became very
controversial and there was a kind of
division although we shouldn't
overemphasize this dichotomy necessarily
between pro-an rationalists and anti-
Myans what was the place of reason and
philosophy in Jewish life these topics
are quite complicated and the categories
between reason and mysticism aren't
really clear at all many have even
claimed that myones himself the arch
rationalist had a mystical side to him
my friend zevi from the channeled
Seekers of unity has made a whole series
on the topic of my
monod's mysticism or not mysticism
that's that's the question right so if
you're interested in that topic then go
check out those wonderful videos
whatever the case it is in this vibrant
environment that kabalah is born of
course most likely as a result of this
chaotic and and really just very
eventful intellectual and mystical
climate many would say even that cabala
kind of emerges as a response to myON
and rationalism as a way of sort of
saying you know identifying themselves
as the opposite of that you know we are
not my monans so that instead we present
this new this other way of interpreting
Judaism which becomes
kabala and while there might be some
truth to this certainly I think a lot of
cabala is in response to the What was
seen as the extreme rationalism the
radical rationalism of someone like
mes we should be careful
about making two simplistic claims about
such things um this dichotomy between
cabala or mysticism and philosophy U
doesn't always hold and one very good
example of why that is is a single man
and that is Abraham
abulafia but before we jump into the
details of people like abulafia and
others like him what is kabala to begin
with well as you have hopefully picked
up on at this point it isn't a single
thing but several schools of thought and
practice usually connected by certain
key features but often also very
distinct from each other the word cabala
essentially means something deceived and
is often therefore translated as
tradition indeed the cabalists
themselves view their tradition as one
that stretches back to the Bible itself
a kind of esoteric dimension of the
Jewish religion that is restricted to
certain kinds of
people a common idea in cabala and
Jewish mysticism as it is in so many
other Traditions is that there are
different levels or Dimensions to
scripture scripture such as the Bible
may say one thing on the surface but
there's a whole o of meaning hiding
beneath the plain words indeed it is
common within Judaism and cabala
particularly to divide biblical reading
into four levels literal the surface
level elusive allegorical and lastly the
mystical level and although cabalistic
reading of scripture is often very
literal almost hyper literal it can be
said that they sometimes through this
hyper literalism actually are concerned
with these hidden mystical dimensions of
what is said in Scripture and preserved
in the Jewish tradition as a whole there
are specific techniques of discovering
these true meanings and often spiritual
practices aimed at things like you know
purifying the soul or the intellect and
approaching or interacting with the
Divine realm but what this means on a
more specific level can differ depending
on which school of cabala we're talking
about and to return then to our
narrative the 13th century Mystic
philosopher Abraham abolafia is one of
the earliest C
who developed a kind of system and
practice that is very different from the
cabala that most people know by
combining the rationalist philosophy of
myones with the mystical teachings found
in books like the saur and probably
other sources um including probably
Sufism and the athetic ashiism in
northern Europe at that time he started
something that has come to be known as
either prophetic cabala or ecstatic
kabalah I've already made a full episode
on abolafia and his teacher teachings
which honestly is probably one of my
favorite videos that I've made um ABA is
just such an incredibly fascinating
figure so uh go check out that episode
if you're interested in learning more
about him but as a shorter overview
abulafia cabala is one that is primarily
focused on what you could call different
kinds of meditative practice and the
employment and speculation about the
mystical powers of the Hebrew letters
abolafia describes different often
complex forms of meditation which often
include vocalizing Hebrew words and
letters uh moving the head in certain
ways and other involved techniques with
the aim of thus having a mystical
experience in different stages where
one's intellect becomes somehow
separated from the body until one
reaches the ultimate goal of the path
which is known as deot or cleaving to
God where one is united with the active
intellect and ultimately at least
According to some interpretations United
with God himself abulafia says quote the
ultimate composite which is man who
comprises all the spot and whose
intellect is the active intellect and
when you will untie its knots you will
be United with it the active intellect
in a unique Union this cleaving or Union
is described occasionally by abolafia in
pretty radical ways quote for now he is
no longer separated from his master and
behold he is his master and his master
is he for he is so intimately United
with him that he cannot by any means be
separated from him for he is he abolafia
depictions of the mystical experiences
that can be had while practicing his
prophetic cabala can be very colorful
involving visions of Light Spirit
doubles and many other things in terms
of his philosophical language as we can
see from his uses of Concepts like the
active intellect is essentially directly
taken from myones which is a good
example to show that this dichotomy
between rationalism and mysticism often
becomes quite inaccurate unless we we
significantly Nuance that discussion as
well what can also be interpreted as
quite radical in abulafia kabala is that
he considers the person who have reached
this experience of full deot the utmost
mystical experience to essentially be
prophets this is something that he also
gets pretty directly from myones the
highest mystical experience is a
prophetic experience making prophecy in
a way the goal of his whole system this
is indeed why it is called prophetic
kabalah abulafia says again quote he
prophesies according to the entity which
causes him to pass from potentiality
into the final and perfect actuality and
he and he become one entity Inseparable
during the ACT but abulafia was quite
controversial too as you can imagine and
his quote unquote school so to say
didn't really survive in any concrete
way especially not in the cabalistic
heartlands of Spain and France although
the ideas of prophetic cabala would
survive in places like the Middle East
and be revived occasionally as well as
influencing some significant later
developments in Jewish mysticism which
we will get to but at the same time that
abolafia was active in Spain and Italy
other significant things were happening
in the same place and frankly in
connection with him namely a movement
where famous and prominent scholars in
Spain and Southern France would develop
a quite different kind of cabala one
that was much more speculative and
metaphysically oriented this early
movement is associated with figures like
Isaac the Blind and provance the circles
in gerona and Castile and major Rabin
and cabalistic figures like nak
manes taking their cue from earlier
works like these saer Haba here this led
to an absolute explosion of mystical
development and speculation and in some
ways all of this culminated in a single
work an absolutely Monumental and
massive piece of literature entitled The
Zohar I'm sure many of you have heard of
this book book and for good reason it
has come to be the main representative
of kabalah in many ways it cannot be
overstated just how important this work
is with many Jews essentially
considering its scripture especially
earlier on in history this book was
essentially canonized as part of Jewish
scripture
for I would say most of of of Jews
around the world the Zohar is a work
that kind of defies any simple
explanation it's a massive work as we
said um I think in the recent um
translation in the uh by by Daniel Matt
um it comes out I think to 12 volumes of
text which is quite significant right so
it's a very big text it's a very
difficult text um
incredibly dense and and hard to
understand sometimes but so so
fascinating and so significant and
important for Jewish mysticism and
cabala in particular The Narrative of
the book follows the second century
Jewish Sage Shimon bokai as he's St ring
with his friends in the hills of Judea
but through the conversations meetings
and events that occur to them the work
explores all conceivable aspects of
Jewish life and religion from law and
practice to Theology and of course
esoteric cabalistic speculation it is
the Zohar that serves as the gold
standard for cabala for most of
history there is some disagreement on
who wrote this work the traditional
account within Judaism and cabala is
that it was actually written by shiman
Bay himself in the 2 Century remaining
basically secret to all but a few until
the late 13th century when it was
revealed to the public so to say and the
book is indeed written kind of ancient
Aramaic albeit a very flawed and unusual
Aramaic which sort of adds to this image
that it is trying to present of itself
however most Scholars today are pretty
sure that the work was actually composed
in the 13th century by the Spanish Rabbi
and cabalist Moshe Deon at least a
significant chunk of the book seems to
come from the pen of mha De Leon but it
is possible that the authorship is more
diverse since the work is essentially a
collection of different very strange and
difficult text from Bible commentaries
to baffling stories so even though most
attributed to M Deon and he probably
wrote at least a significant chunk of
the text um it might have been a sort of
group project with with a group centered
around mosha de Leon who sort of wrote
it collectively we we don't know for
sure but certainly it seems to come from
this this uh group or this cabalistic
environment in Castile in particular it
is thus a direct result of the
environment in Northern Spain and
Southern France and like I said
represents a kind of culmination of that
whole development a work that would come
to Define Jewish mysticism going forward
the kind of cabala that the Zohar comes
from and helped Define in shape is
widely known as theosophical cabala and
it is this kind of cabala that most of
us are familiar with so what is it well
unlike ecstatic cabala which is a lot
more anthropocentric concerned with the
mystical experience of the individual
person theosophical cabala is more
theocentric concerned primarily with
mapping out the Divine world its
relationship to this world and how the
everyday Jewish religious practices and
Commandments the mitzvot are connected
to the vast Divine realities and
Concepts The Scholar of Jewish mysticism
Moshe idel said about theosophical cabal
that it quote encompasses two Central
subjects theosophy a theory of the
elaborate structure of the Divine world
and the ritualistic and experiential way
of relating to the Divinity in order to
induce a state of Harmony this is a
highly theocentric form of religiousness
that while not ignoring the needs of the
human being tends to conceive of
religious Perfection as instrumental for
exerting effective influence on high and
that quot the topics dealt with by this
lore are the nature of the tense F wrote
and the mystical meaning of The
Commandments this I think captures it
pretty well theosophical cabala is an
incredibly complex and diverse
intellectual tradition that sort of
tries to map out the relationship
between the Divine World which is
represented primarily by the tens fot
that we mentioned earlier and the human
world that we live in and what the best
human response is to that relationship
although there are of course different
schools and you know diverse array of
interpretations and nuances within this
tradition but generally theosophical
cabala can kind of be defined as being
concerned with with that topic in
particular so the relationship between
the Divine world the T fot relationship
within the Divine World between the t f
but also the relationship between that
Divine world and our world and how the
the Commandments the mitzvot of the
Jewish law um is the way to establish
the the proper relationship ship between
those two worlds this is what the
cabalists and the cabalistic literature
is primarily concerned with and many
would argue that there's significant
influence here from the philosophical
School of neoplatonism but in a way the
issue that the cabalists are dealing
with is essentially the same as that of
the
neoplatonist how do we go from an
infinite God an absolutely Eternal
infinite and perfect principle Beyond
any limitation and conception to a
created world full of limitation and
flaws they seem pretty mutually
exclusive so how does one come from the
other how do we Bridge the two the
neoplatonists as you will know conceived
of different hypostases or realities
that emanated and in steps eventually
became the physical world from the one
or God Comes The Noose or intellect or
mind after which comes soul and then we
get the sensible world even though these
realities are interconnected and
according to many interpretations they
all sort of take place within each other
the cabalists had a very similar
solution and were perhaps of course we
could argue influenced by the
neoplatonists in cabalistic terminology
God in his absolute form is referred to
with the term
a aof means the infinite and is a term
that denotes the absolutely ineffable
Divine as it is in itself before self-
manifestation this is a completely
Transcendent principle beyond the grasp
of human reason or understanding nothing
can be said about it but this principle
is the source or Creator you could say
of the phenomenal world and here we have
that problem right how does one come
from the other well we already have the
answer God emanates God self God's light
in stages and these emanations and
stages are the 10
spot each spot represents a kind of
attribute of God as God becomes
particularized and in a kind of
descending order from Top Which is
closest to the ins to the bottom the
names of the tens fot are ker meaning
Crown HMA meaning wisdom Bina
understanding loving kindness G power or
judgment tiet Beauty n trium for
endurance Majesty yod foundation and
malut Kingdom that last SP malut is very
important not only for being identified
with this world in a sense or at least
the the the stage before this world but
also for being identified with the the
sh is indeed another one of the key
Concepts in cabala and key to
understanding their vision of God the
had been a part of Jewish thought for a
long time and denoted God's presence in
the world God as we said is utterly
transcendant in the form of a but
according to Judaism God is also
imminent in the world God God interacts
with the world inspires prophets and
Visionaries in kabalah this is how that
is explained the is the last SP which is
present in the world and very
interestingly the sh is understood as
being female in nature in other words
the is the divine feminine identified as
God's presence in the world and
identical to the last of malut so this
is the Divine structure in theosophical
cabala an infinite Divine principle
which emanates itself in stages the spot
to create the world and is present in
the world through the feminine side of
God or the what is known as the and
while there are many different thinkers
who have modified details or aspects
this is the basic features of
theosophical cabala expounded in works
like the important Zohar but what does
this mean for the human being how do we
interact with this Divine realm and
what's the purpose of all this well this
is where it gets a little complicated as
if it wasn't already complicated clearly
there is a relationship between the
Divine world of the spot and the human
world some conceive the idea that the
attributes of the spot are mirrored or
can be found in this world and even that
there's a kind of mirror of the T fot
inside the human being the microcosm and
macrocosm idea again as such these SPO
need to be balanced and United within
the human person in his mind and actions
and and behavior in different ways
through religious observ es and
spiritual practices in terms of the
theosophical cabala there's a certain
theurgic element to it meaning that we
somehow interact and even affect the
Divine World in some
way theosophical cabala as expressed in
works like the Zohar is primarily
concerned on the Practical level with
the observance of the Jewish
Commandments in the Bible the so-called
mitzvot now this doesn't just mean the
famous Ten Commandments that Moses
received on Mount Si but all the Jewish
Commandments ments included in the Bible
which make up Jewish law and practice
the the cabalist speculated about the
fot and the Divine world but also
conceived of the importance of the
mitzvot in terms of its relationship
with the spot in other words the deeper
mystical meanings and purposes behind
Jewish practices like prayer for
instance a kind of deepening of one's
consciousness of the significance of
practice and the idea of the
correspondence between the Divine and
human world also becomes important as
the cabalist emphasize different ways of
unification or unifying the different
spher both within oneself and outside so
to say this is a complicated idea but it
hints at one of the more radical aspects
of this system of the spal the idea that
us as human beings can somehow affect
the Divine world now we should remember
that God the aor is perfect and utterly
Beyond any change or imperfection in
Jewish theology but there is still an
openness to the idea that our actions
affect and interact with the spot in
different ways this becomes perhaps most
apparent with developments in the 16th
century when there appeared a cabalistic
circle in the city of svat or safed in
which we can see an explosion of
cabalistic activity and Innovation these
activities are primarily associated with
figures in safed like mosha Cordo ysf
Caro Yak Lua and his student Bal mosha
Cordo the first one mentioned is to my
mind one of the most interesting Jewish
Mystics in history and it's sad that he
isn't known and studied more than he is
outside the Jewish World of course
famous primarily for composing a massive
work entitled The pares rimonim or
Orchard of pomegranates Cordo
systematized the teachings of the Zohar
and cabala in very impressive ways while
also reincorporating certain aspects of
ecstatic cabala associated with Abraham
abolafia such as the mystical gold of
deot or Union cleaving to God and the
more meditative practices that came with
it but his most widely popular work is
probably a book entitled The Tom dor the
palmre of d'vorah which is essentially a
book of Ethics that connects to the
essential ideas of philosophical cabala
this is an absolutely beautiful book
which at its core explores the idea of
imito day imitation of God and this is
where it connects to the themes we have
been discussing
previously the goal in life is to
imitate God by embodying and manifesting
the attributes of the Divine spot this
means not only observing the mitzvot and
the Jewish law in a sort of particular
way but generally also thinks like being
a kind loving and caring person that
gives and cares for their fellow human
beings and creatures explaining how to
embody the attributes of ker he says
quote no reason whatsoever should
prevent him from doing good to others
always and at every moment and no
transgressions or misdeeds of unworthy
people should stop him from bestowing
good on those in need and just as God
sustains all creatures from the highest
to the lowest despising none of them for
if he despised any creatures because of
their insignificance they would not
exist even for a moment watching over
them and showing compassion to all so
too should man do good to all not
despising any creature even the lowliest
being should be very important in his
eyes and he should show concern for them
doing good to all who require his
goodness by mirroring and embodying the
spot through these principles and
behaviors we become more quote unquote
like God and by becoming more like God
we are connecting ourselves to the
Divine world and in a way accomplishing
God's creation by performing the essence
of God's attributes on Earth completing
its very purpose we are active
participants in the purpose and aim of
creation and play our role fully by
imitating God this is an idea that
stretches back further in history and
myones himself saw it as key to ethics
he said quote the chief aim of man
should be to make himself as far as
possible similar to God that is to say
to make his acts similar to the acts of
God but covo of course takes this a step
further by implementing the cabalistic
ideas of the spot as a key aspect of
this teaching in an truly ingenious way
Cordova's younger contemporary insaf
however y GLA is more famous and
influential in the history of
kabalah passing away at the young age of
38 he had in a short few years
absolutely transformed kabalah and given
it the form that most of us know today
indeed when you are taught about kabalah
and its teachings today it's usually the
so-called lurianic cabala that is taught
as Laura's ideas became so influential
and the innovations that Laura made to
the system is perhaps the most striking
example of the idea that our actions can
affect the Divine world first of all
Lura is significant for introducing the
idea of timum or contraction remember
when we talked about the a s and how it
creates the world by limiting its light
into the emanations of the spot well
there's still the question of how an
infinite absolute principle can even
become or create something Limited in
itself doesn't that kind of limit the
ano by introducing the creation of
limits within it well Lura solved this
problem by introducing the idea of
contraction or
symtom when the inso creates quote
unquote the world it has to contract
from itself to create a kind of void or
empty space within its itself into which
it can then pour its light into the
vessels of the spot and eventually
create the world this is of course a
really fascinating and interesting way
to solve this issue and when it's become
very famous and popular since then if
you studied cabala again you've probably
heard about this concept of the symtom
it's become a kind of standard way of
explaining the creation of the World by
the an but this was actually introduced
by Lura in the 17th or 16th century
furthermore in the process of this
emanation something goes wrong according
to
Lua as the SPO are created he imagines
them almost as vessels into which the
Anor pours his light or his being as if
you poured water into glass vessels for
instance but the light of the ins is so
strong and powerful that the vessels
can't contain it as a result the vessels
shatter and as they shatter the shards
of these vessels descend down into our
world and very significantly these
shards are the cause of all evil in the
world in other words this is a very
unique explanation for the problem of
theodicy or the problem of evil in the
world and it is through this that Lura
also introduces his strongly
participatory cabalistic
theosophy what happens when we perform
the mitzvot and embody the attributes of
this fot when we pray or give to the
poor in a striking way Lura explains
that through these practices we are
helping these shards of the broken
vessels Ascend back into the Divine
world and gradually heal the Sparro
again in other words human actions can
literally affect and even heal the
Divine World in some way and by healing
the Divine we also Heal the World a
famous concept known as tikun which
literally means healing the world thus
here theosophical kabala is given a very
clear and obvious practical side and
purpose not only does it explain the
Divine world and the deeper mytical
meanings behind their Commandments for
instance it also explains how the
performance of those Commandments
directly participates in the healing of
the Divine and the world in a way to
express it in a radical way we complete
God and again this lurana cabala since
then has become the kind of cabala that
most of us are taught this becomes
cabala um the ideas of Laura become the
way that most theosophical cabalists
since then understand this system and
how it works right but this should not
be confused with um or or should not be
taken to the extreme we must still
remember of course that um there have
been other interpretations right before
lria like even Cordo who was his
contemporary in the same city in the
same he had a different reading of these
things he interpreted the Zohar in
different ways Lura was very Innovative
he was very unique and and and those
ideas that he presents is not present
before him in cabala and even after him
of course not every cabalist agrees with
him so before and after there is a
diversity in cabala right even within
the so-called theosophical cabala um
there are different thinkers both then
and now that that innovate that see
things in from different perspectives
that that don't agree with lri and have
different interpretations of these
things so that should be kept in mind on
top of the fact that things like
ecstatic or prophetic kabalah has also
been a thing you know for most of
History um and and that's also what's
significant about this circle in safed
with people like Cordo and laua is that
they sort of incorporate both um the
theosophical strands of cabala
associated with the Zohar with the
ecstatic teachings and practices of of
abolafia for instance and this synthesis
that happens in safed is one of the
reasons why it's so significant because
this circle in safed cord and especially
Laura as we see uh just completely
changes the face of kabalah it it really
is a very significant
moment
but again we must point out the fact
that there isn't one cabala but many
different kinds of cabala there is the
theosophical one which has diversity
within it there is ecstatic cabala or
prophetic cabala and there are even
other forms of Jewish mysticism still
happening across that whole history that
is neither of these two there was also
for example the ptic mystical movement
in Egypt in the 13th century headed by
Abraham the son of myones which took
major inspiration from the Islamic sufis
and introduced Innovations in prayer
practice that looked a lot like Muslim
prayer and introduced mystical and
aesthetic practices also clearly
influenced by Sufism and I've explored
this group in a previous episode too and
the most recent major form of Jewish
mysticism is also arguably a unique case
and that is of course hassidism
appearing in the 18th century ISM has
become incredibly popular and in many
ways introduced ideas of Jewish
mysticism which were previously the
exclusive concern of the elite the
intellectual Elite to the general masses
to introduce us to kism orid here is my
friend and colleague zevi from the
channel Seekers of Unity thank you
Phillip kism is a religious revivalistic
movement which emerged in mid 18th
century Eastern Europe under the
inspiration of Y the balov of literally
the master of the good name the bmov was
orphaned at a young age and at least
according to one version of The
Narrative was taken in by a secretive
Brotherhood of Jewish Mystics and under
that tutelage developed his own unique
form of Jewish mysticism which placed a
heavy emphasis on Simplicity and
authenticity in the worship of God and
service to once's fellow the bmov would
go into to teach this way of life to his
students most notably to do be the Magid
the preacher of mezrich the maged the
architect of kism would go and to
propagate his M's teachings by
formalizing and teaching them to a
select Inner Circle of disciples who
would go to spread these teachings
across Eastern Europe effectively
creating a mass movement to spread his
master of the bm's teachings the first
of its kind in the history of Jewish
mysticism throughout Jewish history
mysticism had been restricted to a
narrow CAD of elite Scholars kism was
the first time when the teachings and
practices of Jewish mysticism reached a
sustained Mass audience spreading
rapidly across the landscape of Eastern
European jewry but not without its
detractors with the memory of the
devastating failure of the Satine
movement still fresh in their minds
members of The urbin Establishment
launched a fierce oppositional movement
against the young fledgling cassic
movement which culminated in an
excommunication of the cic movement in
1781 this firm opposition however had
the opposite of its intended effect
instead of shutting down the movement it
ended up bolstering it and helped cement
its folk identity as a spiritual Revival
of the common folk against the elite by
the time the maged the student of the
bamv passed away in
1772 20 or so of his handpicked
disciples had been dispersed to see the
movement all over Eastern Europe and
further field within a few short
Generations the kasic movement
transitioned from a ragtag band of rural
Mystics to a well-established movement
with major dynasties courts and centers
of pilgrimage across Lithuania white
Russia Ukraine Galia and
Poland with the onset of World War II
the cidic world suffered a major blow
the Holocaust eradicated large swaths of
theic world tragically wiping out entire
dynasties and decimating others many
historians believed that the history of
kism had come to an end but following
the war kism picked itself Back Up From
the Ashes rebuilt its communities and
flourished in new lands both in the
United States Israel and
elsewhere kism lives on today not merely
as a relic of a rich past but as a
vibrant living Force into the the future
adding to the rich tapestry of the
Jewish World with its unique flavor of
religious spiritual cultural lurgical
artistic and human expression part of
the challenge of defining classtic
thought is the sheer diversity of
expression and articulation which
emerges even within the very first
generations of kism with each of the
early masses expressing their own
spiritual voice in unique ways among the
early Masters we find those who
practiced ticism
negating the material world While others
preached against aestheticism and
embraced the Divinity hidden within the
world some advocate for a static Union
with God While others prefer a
contemplative approach to the Divine we
find some preaching a explicitly
Messianic Doctrine While others negating
it we find some teaching pantheistic and
acosmic theologies While others choose
to emphasize God's Transcendence and
radical otherness some are stonch haks
and theorists of Jewish law While others
flirt with
antinomianism some highlight the
centrality of kabala in their thinking
While others shun it and the same goes
for Jewish philosophy some Embrace and
engage with it deeply While others
outright forbid it despite this
diversity however there are some common
themes which we can try and Trace out
that might unite cic thought into a
cohesive H without forgetting the above
mentioned
disclaimer as opposed to an aesthetic
semity that had dominated religious
practice prior to kism theic movement in
large placed an emphasis on worshiping
god with joy and happiness song and
dance love and ecstasy cidic thought and
practice at its finest is marked by an
intoxication with divinity authenticity
and
humility worshiping God for theic master
is as it is for many Mystics seen as an
opportunity to approach be in the
presence of and to even perhaps couple
and Unite with the Divine through the
inner work the aod ofm particularly in
the act of devotional prayer theic
Mystic strives to strip away their ego
to nullify and integrate the self in an
act of B like a seed which is placed
into the dirt shedding its protective
layering disintegrating into the ground
so that it can be reborn again into the
form of a tree the soul which inic
thought is literally a part of God
likewise needs to strip itself of it
shell of the ego which keeps it trapped
in its own identity so that it can break
down in exstasy and find itself reborn
in God in what the Masters
call this is the central aim of kism to
unite the true self the soul with true
being namely God this Union allows the
human to see reality clearly as a
manifestation of divinity to recognize
God in all things not just in moments of
sanctioned Holiness but even and
particularly in the ordinary and the
mundane this was the Messianic
realization and the state of being that
the bmov strove to impart to his
students and they to the Jewish masses
by spreading his Wellsprings and
teaching all how to unite themselves in
God how to unite with
reality the Theology and metaphysics of
kism orbit around the attempt to
reconcile Divine Transcendence and
divine imminence they represent a
persistent attempt to answer the age-old
question of how God can both be
infinitely and categorically above and
beyond our reality and yet deeply
invested and present in every moment of
it the cidic discourse on this age old
challenge joins a global choir of voices
explicating mystical theologies of the
one and the many from platinus to iban
Ari from pseudo dianis to Simon Way
kism picked up the conversation where
cabala had left off dovetailing their
cosmological analysis directly into the
cabalistic discussions of Tsum Divine
self-contraction shim the cosmic
cataclysmic shattering that preceded our
present iteration of reality and the
work of
aim the work to recollect and raise the
Fallen Sparks of divinity back up to be
reintegrated into their Source in the
fiery ploma of the
Divine parallel to this macrocosmic work
of restoring Divinity to its original
form and form of Glory is the work of
theid upon themselves the microcosmic
the work to reorient all of ones mid dos
emotional intellectual and ethical
character traits towards love and
kindness towards God reintegrating the
disperate parts of ourselves back into
our true self there's no doubt that all
of these ideas place Central roles in
the formation and function of kism
perhaps between the dance of all of
these doctrines something of the essence
of kism can be
glimpsed if you'd like to learn more
about kism check out Philip's brilliant
video on the subject and now back to you
philli thank you so much seie for the
beautiful explanation for anyone out
there who hasn't yet go check out his
channel seers of unity subscribe to that
channel it's it's truly some beautiful
content especially if you're interested
in these kinds of topic that we're
talking about today zevi is your guy so
check out his channel hasidism is really
interesting because it combines many
different aspects of Jewish mysticism
from over the centuries into a new and
fascinating movement cism is still very
popular around the world while the role
of kabala generally was somewhat
negatively affected by the reform
movements within Judaism in the 18th and
19th century and the rise of a more
exclusionary rationalism and of course
the the very dramatic events of the uh
the figure of shabti the so-called false
Messiah who in the 17th century
convinced most of the Jewish world that
he was indeed the Messiah and then one
day converts to Islam uh and and his
sort of claim to be the Messiah is very
much connected to cabala and mysticism
and lanic cabala in particular that was
a huge disaster in many ways and also
kind of in some ways gave cabala a bit
of a bad name in certain circles that
certainly helped this process of cabala
being a less prominent in many movements
of Judaism today works like the Zohar
lost its status as scripture to many and
just like in other context like the
Islamic World mysticism was increasingly
seen as superstitious and detrimental to
a pure rational religion but with
hassidism which was born at the same
time we see a new kind of Jewish
mysticism which combines many of the
different currents and movements in
history and a kind of democratization of
mysticism itself it was no longer just a
concern for the intellectual Elite but
for everyone kism is a deeply mystical
tradition that has grown immensely
popular across the Jewish world even
today the 20th century also saw the
increased interest in the academic study
of Jewish mysticism and one of the most
heated debates regarding Jewish
mysticism in modern scholarship has been
the question of the mystical Union or
Union mystica in the vast world of quote
unquote mysticism one of the most
recurring themes is indeed this idea of
achieving some kind of Union with higher
realities and often even the conception
of a union with God God s we find this
in Sufism in Christian mysticism in
platonism but does this idea exist in
Judaism indeed Judaism puts a great
emphasis on the idea of God's
Transcendence and the clear boundary
between God and the created world so
does this even allow for the idea of
Union in this way the most prominent
scholar of Jewish mysticism of the 20th
century gersam sholam argued that it
doesn't to him and those who followed
him the Jewish Mystics with very rare
exceptions never went as far as saying
that there could be any sort of direct
Union with God and this was the
prevailing idea for a long time and can
be found in a lot of literature about
mysticism and Judaism generally but in
the last few decades Scholars like MOSI
idel have gone against this idea and
instead argued that not only does it
exist in Jewish mysticism the idea of
the mystical Union is indeed quite
prominent and common and this stance is
gaining more and more popularity we've
seen in this episode many examples of a
kind of unitive language from the
earliest writers such as Pho of
Alexandria we find the idea that the
human can Ascend to God and even unite
in some way Pho writes that quote he
bids them to cleave to him bringing out
by the use of this word how constant and
continuous and unbroken is the Concord
and Union that comes through making God
our our own in the case of Philo though
it doesn't seem like a full Union with
God but with an aspect of God namely the
logos but later in history we get more
clear expressions of the mystical Union
perhaps most prominently in the ecstatic
cabala and writings of people like
abolafia who talk about the goal of
davot or cleaving precisely as a kind of
Union where in abolafia words quote he
and he become one entity Inseparable
during the ACT slightly later the
fascinating but relatively little alone
cabalist Rabbi Isaac of acre wrote about
mystical Union using the language of
water which definitely mirrors the
thought and earlier quote of abolafia
quote she the soul will cleave to the
Divine intellect and it will cleave to
her and she and the intellect become one
entity as if somebody pours out a jug of
water into a running well that all
becomes one this idea further shows up
in safan cabala and also quite
prominently in hassidism which has a
quite outright monistic or even
pantheistic adjacent theology sometimes
where God is everywhere and where
realizing this Unity becomes an
important feature do of Metar one of the
foundational figures of early kism wrote
that quote a man must separate himself
from any corporeal things to such an
extent that he will Ascend through all
the worlds and be in Union with God
until his existence will be
annihilated with all that said all this
of course also comes down to
interpretation and how we choose to read
some of these passages but I think with
all this in mind it at least to me it
becomes hard to defend a kind
of hard anti- UN mystica in Judaism I
think Scholars like idel and many others
um by studying people like this and and
looking at some of these writings that
we've explored um have shown clearly
enough that the idea of the mystical
Union with God in some way seems
certainly pretty common across the
history of Jewish mysticism and
different ways today the situation is of
course quite complex as it has always
been there has been a Resurgence of
interest in cabala in the last couple of
decades and kabah is taught in various
places around the world sometimes deeply
connected to traditional Judaism
sometimes with a more Universalist and
maybe even New Age interpretation we've
seen several celebrities show interest
in cabala and bring it to a wider
audience such as perhaps most notably
Madonna at the same time kism continues
to be one of the most prominent mov
movements within Judaism embodying
Traditions that are centuries old in
other words while Jewish mysticism has
evolved over the centuries and taken on
many different forms it remains a very
significant and important part of one of
the most significant and largest
religions in the world thank you to zevi
and Justin for being part of this video
um really appreciate and always love
it's an honor working together with with
such talented and and beautiful human
beings so go check out their channels
esoterica and SE speakers of unity and
you will not regret it uh also don't
forget that I just released my new song
ismus with my project zeni if you're
interested in the music that I make
which is the music of the majority of
the videos on this channel the music is
made by me and I just put out a new song
two weeks ago depending on when this
comes out recently I put on a new song
so uh there will be links to that in the
description as well if you're interested
and lastly of course I want to extend a
special thank you to all my patrons who
as I always say they keep this channel
going and none of this would be possible
possible without you so thank you from
the depths of my heart for all the
support thank you again to the patrons
thank you for everyone who likes who
watches who comments and who engages
with these videos and in this wonderful
beautiful Community uh that I'm very
proud to to be a part of so thank you
all so much for watching and I will see
you next
[Music]
time